Petite mise en place
Briefing avec l'équipe technique
Salut, hier j'étais en tournée
et je n'avais pas mon ordinateur avec moi
et je me suis aperçu
d'un gros bug
La vidéo que j'avais programmé hier à 17h
n'avait pas la fin.
Je ne sais pas comment c'est possible
J'ai téléchargé depuis la version entière de cette vidéo
je vous la met en lien dans la description de celle ci
et je vous met également un lien vers la chaine de Michaël Hirsch
cette chaîne drôle et intelligente que je vous recommande
Aujourd'hui, je voulais revenir sur le discours que François Hollande a eu hier
par rapport à l'arrivée de Donald Trump
C'est une tradition française de féliciter l'arrivée du nouveau président américian
ou de la nouvelle présidente américaine
mais ça n'a jamais été le cas pour l'instant
Alors qu'on soit d'accord avec Trump ou pas
qu'on soit d'accord avec ses idées ou son arrivée ou pas
Ça ne change rien au fait qu'il soit là
et ça ne change rien au fait que ça a bien mis François Hollande dans la galère
Surtout quand on sait que l'Elysée avait prévu
un seul discours
car l'Elysée n'avait prévu et écrit qu'un seul discours
Je vous laisse deviner pour qui
Bref un petit peu en rebond avec les vidéos que j'ai faites la semaine dernière
par rapport aux micros-expressions
Je vous propose une rapide analyse du discours de François Hollande
Dès le départ, on voit bien qu'à sa manière de déglutir et de se positionner
et même de prendre son inspiration
il n'est pas très à l'aise
Non, il est pas à l'aise
Là il préférerait être très très loin d'ici
Je pense également qu'il a été coaché
d'une manière générale les hommes politiques sont coachés mais là précisément
parce qu'il sait qu'il va être le centre d'attention du monde entier
vis à vis de cette déclaration là
tout le monde va la regarder en tout cas, au moins une fois c'est sûr
Il y a une vraie recherche de maîtrise du visage durant tout ce discours
Ce qui explique peut être pourquoi les 2 sourcils
sont légèrement verrouillés
peut être pour empêcher des mouvements
Il fait comme ça, il contracte légèrement les sourcils
Autant vous dire qu'il aurait mieux fait de contracter tout le reste
parce que durant toute la vidéo j'ai eu l'impression de voir Tigrou
Il rebondissait de partout
Il y a pas d'ancrage, il est pas à l'aise
il cherche un appui en permanence
ce qui explique que son bras gauche soit toujours en contact avec le pupitre
quand c'est pas les 2 bras. Il cherche un appui quelque part
Je ne sais même pas si, il est resté dans la même position plus de 3 secondes d'affilés
Alors, il y a 2 explications possibles
Soit il cherche un ancrage dans le sol, il arrive pas être sur ces appuis, il est pas à l'aise
soit il a une envie très pressante
très très pressante
Je vous laisse choisir
Le résultat des votes aux Etats Unis ne l'arrange pas
ça l'agace même
On le voit à plusieurs endroits avec le pincement des lèvres, avec la dilatation des narines
[François Hollande] Cette élection américaine ouvre une période d'incertitude
F: il éprouve d'ailleurs du mépris ici
[François Hollande] lucidité et clarté
On reconnait l'asymétrie au coin des lèvres
et celui ci est magnifique c'est le recul qu'il a à ce moment là
c'est un signe typique du mépris
et on l'a également lorsqu'il parle de Donald Trump président
de l'Amérique
[François Hollande] Donald Trump durant la campagne américaine
*au ralenti* Campagne Américaine
F: Il y a un truc amusant, c'est qu'il nous donne également dans son discours
un pléonasme corporel et son inverse
Je vous laisse juste regarder cette extrait en pleine écran
[François Hollande] ouvre une période d'incertitude
*au ralenti* d'incertitude
F: Vous avez pu voir ici que tout son corps fait Oui
ça acquiesce vraiment ce qu'il est en train de dire
alors que plus loin
quand on voit ça
[François Hollande] Les Etats Unies constitue un partenaire
F: Bon ben là vous l'avez clairement vu quand il aborde la notion de partenaire
un gros Non comme ça
Pas très envie François
Tout tourne autour d'une vraie déception pour François Hollande
on peut la voir ici
parce que c'est pas le plan qu'il avait projeté, qu'il avait prévu
et c'est là, je crois, que se situe toute l'interprétation de tout ce qu'on vient de dire
Hollande est pas du tout centré sur les élections américaines
il est centré sur les prochaines élections françaises
d'une part avec la peur de ce qui pourrait se passer en France
parce que là, on est en train de constater que quand les électeurs
sont dans l'isoloir
c'est là où ils ont vraiment le pouvoir et ils peuvent même
mettre quelque chose juste pour voir ce que ça fait
en fait, de redistribuer le jeu différement
et d'autre part, il a constaté que les français
et c'est sûr, il a constaté, au moins via les réseaux sociaux
il a des communicants pour ça qui lui en parle
que le peuple Français été globalement contre Trump
Et même si on a toutes les raisons de l'être,
il y a eu aussi un petit effet de mode comme ça durant 24h hier
Du coup, en faisant le discours tel qu'il l'a fait,
François Hollande, il fait 2 choses
Il joue une tour sur son échiquier pour faire comprendre aux Français qu'il est de l'avis de la majorité d'entre eux
mais il se fait aussi manger un cavalier dans sa relation internationale
parce que, qu'on le veuille ou non
Donald Trump est président des Etats Unies
Enfin il prend ces fonctions au mois de janvier
Mais ça va être lui le nouveau président
du coup, je suis pas sûr et certain
qu'il kiffe cette acceuil
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, n'oubliez pas de laisser un like
si vous avez aimé ce concept de prendre une vidéo récente, un discours et de...
vous le détaillez
N'hésitez pas à vous exprimer dans les commentaires,
mais je vous demanderai de rester respectueux dans les échanges
J'ai beaucoup de chance, moi, vis à vis de la communauté dont vous faites parti
c'est que j'ai une communauté cool et bienveillante
donc j'espère que d'aborder un sujet un peu plus politique
un sujet comme ça, ça va pas changer la donne.
Pour info je suis en spectacle, avec toujours avec Fabien Olicard vous mentalise
qui est un mélange de mentalisme et d'humour
que certains ont déjà découvert sur scène
le 10 décembre à Clay sous bois
le 31 décembre pour la dernière journée de l'année
je serai à Versailles à la Royal Factory
et en Janvier les première date de janvier ce sont les 6 et 7 à Lille au Spotlight
Je vous met un lien vers toutes les dates de spectacle
dans la descriptions de la vidéo
Si vous venez n'hésiter pas à attendre à la fin du spectacle
Je prends toujours du temps pour qu'on se rencontre, pour qu'on discute parce que
il y a pas qu'à vous que ça fait plaisir, à moi aussi
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir
parce que le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre, c'est ça le défi de cette année
et on avance tranquillement
on avance.
Rendez vous demain à 17h
Tchao !